uh we've got a headline here from the
daily caller this is a couple days ago
because you know these left wing woke
progressive whatever the hell you want
to call them at this point these
activists are uh they're always pushing
for the rest of us to be censored so
here's a headline from the daily caller
a few days ago left-wing activists urge
big tech to censor
anti-pedophile
smear now the anti-pedophile smear that
they're referring to is this meme of ok
groomers that's been going around the
internet and this is where people are
calling out all of these sort of gender
queer teachers who want to talk to other
people's children about sexuality and
not report it back to the parents
etc etc you guys get all that well then
uh this uh this is a woman i believe ari
drennon is a woman although i'm not a
biologist
from media matters she's the
lgbtq program director over at media
matters uh she wrote she tweeted this
daily caller we aren't
anti-lgbtq we're anti-pedophile
uh also the daily caller uses a generic
picture of young people holding pride
flags in the article and then here's
where the story hit home james lindsey
tweeted back okay groomer and he was
quickly swiftly dealt with by the
twitter lords he was suspended
james uh you're a mean dude huh you're
you just don't want to play by their
rules and you want to uh you know go on
the attack against people who want to
talk to other people's kids about sex
what's the deal with you
yeah i don't like that when when they
talk to other people's kids about sex
and our mortal enemies are clown trooper
whatever we have over at media matters
or got sick of the little trend i
started i don't know if you knew dave i
started the okay groomer thing back in
october i think i have the first okay
was that you you were actually like the
legit first okay groomer person
i am the first okay groomer that's right
and wow and then i did i did a series of
podcasts i've titled groomer schools
there are four of them the most recent
one i did just a few weeks ago released
a few weeks ago where i read through a
paper talking about drag queen story
hour and i'm not okay with drag queen
story hour i'm not okay with groomers
i'm not okay with whether this is sexual
grooming or ideological cult grooming um
and so i called this out and media
matters couldn't handle this after a
number of months i didn't know
apparently they changed the rule on
twitter back in february without telling
anybody that they had made this an
explicit rule that you can't call
protected classes of people whom i
assume they mean are the t's and the q's
because most lbs and g's are against
the
grooming thing
so you can't call a t or a q within the
alphabet people and maybe some of the
probably most of the pluses if i had to
guess uh you can't call those people
groomers on twitter as they'll mass
report you and then
they'll knock you off and put something
about it in your wikipedia entry
can we call people that support the
groomers groomers i mean i would argue
that people like the biden
administration aoc nancy pelosi at all
are supporting grooming of my children
so
well i get kicked off on twitter if i
call them out for that it's just it's
unbelievable the social media overlords
and what they do and do not allow us to
say
libby do you have a better phrase do you
have a better phrase libby for this i
was on a a radio show i'm not even going
to call the guy out because he's he's a
friendly to most of us i think nice
enough guy but he was asking me a couple
weeks ago about the okay groomer thing
and he said dave do you think it's over
the top and i had said i said to him you
know i've never said it on my show
actually people you know there's a
internet culture and what i do here okay
fine i said but do you have a better
phrase for a group of people who want to
talk to other people's children
six-year-olds about sex and gender and
hide it from their parents you have a
better phrase for it and without
blinking he goes uh what about
indoctrinator and i thought well is that
better than groomer is that worse than
groomer like that's the level of sort of
stupidity that we're dealing with libby
you got a better word than groomer for
these people you know i i don't
necessarily back in april during the
trans day of visibility when president
biden went on twitter and said to
american parents that it was their
responsibility to affirm their kids we
called him the groomer in chief and i do
think that the fact that these activists
are offended by the term groomer and
aligning that term with themselves is
such an insane cell phone do they not
realize that by saying that lgbtq
people uh that's saying using the term
groomer for activists in the lgbtq
movement
um
saying that that's offensive to them is
actually kind of insane and shows that
uh
they must relate to it in some way i
don't see what you can call a third
grade teacher who tells her students to
use all the pronouns and then hides it
from parents hides it from the
administration says that they're this
very safe space for all of this um
indoctrinators grooming indoctrinators
uh
sex advocates for kids i don't know like
i think groomer is actually pretty apt
and this band actually reminds me
six-year-old
yeah it reminds me of when megan murphy
was banned i think in 2018 for saying
yeah him
yeah him
you know really this is what we get
banned for it's just it's so obvious
that this is an agenda-driven
um
you know batch of lies that's being
right and let's see
also let's not forget i mean jordan
peterson is now officially suspended
from twitter because he called ellen
page elliott page i got suspended for
literally referencing the fact that
jordan peterson was suspended i'm still
unclear who was the actress that was in
x-men was that an actor named elliot
page or a woman named ellen page doesn't
matter